[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
the bbc is being urged to give urgent
answers as questions continue over the
dyson report and the corporation's
interview with princess diana
mps from the digital culture media and
sport committee
said they want to know why martin
beshear was rehired in 2016.
the broadcasting regulator ofcom
announced it would now hold talks with
the corporation
prince william meanwhile has resumed his
duties with a visit to scotland
laura bundock reports
his attack on the bbc was blistering
but prince william's back on royal
duties at the start of a tour of
scotland
the strength of his statement though
will resonate
for some time the dyson
inquiry exposed lies deceit and cover-up
and a management that believed the
guilty and failed the innocent
including the whistleblower who first
spoke out
he's matt wiesler the graphic designer
asked to make fake
documents as weeks and months went on i
went up the ladder i went to see head of
programs and then i went to see
you know people beyond that
i never saw tony hall actually but um
i never got an answer i mean it was
literally like
i was the guy that pointed out the flaw
in something really beautiful
which is a scoop and i pointed out that
there was something not right
and all they could think of doing was
turning their back on me
these are some of the key players tim
suter was a bbc
executive he's now resigned from the
board of ofcom
lord hall was the bbc's director general
from 2013
until last year and martin beshear had a
high profile career before returning to
the bbc
as a religious affairs correspondent he
recently stepped down
due to poor health it is curious that
they all
seem to fail at about the same time
and i think what emerges from dyson is
the possibility
that there was how can i put it
generally an understanding
by the bbc editorial executives within
the chain
not to let the truth come out
that truth is now out but although the
inquiry answers some questions
it raises many more just how far
up the chain of command did knowledge of
the interview go
how and why did the bbc's board of
governors accept matt wiesler as a
scapegoat
in 1996 and why did the bbc
re-hire martin beshear in 2016
they're all difficult questions one
former bbc manager says the current
criticism
goes too far i think it's damaged the
bbc
no doubt at all about that but i'm not
sure it's an existential crisis for the
bbc
there are some critics of the bbc uh
people who
are now lecturing the bbc on its
editorial ethics
maybe just one or two of them should be
taking a hard look in the mirror
this definitely isn't over the bbc's
been damaged
and some want a second more detailed
inquiry
if the bbc's to renew trust and restore
its reputation laura bundock sky news
also this morning it's set to be a
landmark day for the vaccine program in
england
anyone aged over 32 has been invited to
book for their jab
and the nhs is expecting to pass 50
million
vaccines well i should say who joins me
now from
the newsroom uh the vaccination program
has been hailed a success
um and this even further proof that it's
doing very well
yeah it's definitely good news in what
has been the nhs's largest
and most successful vaccination drive in
history now as you said today 32 and 33
year olds will be eligible to book in
for their first doze
that's around 1.1 million people that
will be invited to come forward for that
first
jab and it comes alongside another
milestone moment
today in england vaccinations are
expected to pass that 50 million mark
when it comes to
the first and second dozers being
administered that means
in england more than four in ten adults
will be fully vaccinated
and have maximum protection against the
virus and
of course while this is good news there
is still as ever the need for caution
ahead there are concerns over the indian
variant
we've seen cases of the indian variant
rise by 161 percent
within a week and today at the office
for national statistics
have also said that there are early
signs that there could be a potential
increase in positive cases
of covert 19 in england now the numbers
show that 1 in 1 110 people
tested positive for covert 19 in
households
in private households and this is up
from 1 in 1
340 and we also know that the r value
increased in
england up to 0.9 between 0.9 and 1.1
where it was previously 0.8 between 0.8
and 1. now while there is definitely
good news with the vaccination program
and it's really welcome to hear
governments and experts will be
keeping a close eye on potential
increases in cases
okay i should thank you
well let's look at the daily covid
numbers now and there have been 2
829 new cases and nine more deaths have
been reported
that takes the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test
to 127 710
another 268 251 people have received
their first vaccination
and 420 312
they're second in total 59.18 million
jabs have now been administered across
the uk
president biden says a two-state
solution is now the only answer to
resolving the conflict between
israel and the palestinian people
speaking at the white house he said he
was
praying the ceasefire between israel and
hamas holds
there is no shift in my commitment
my commitment to the security of israel
period
no shift not at all but i tell you what
there is a shift in
the shift is that we have to we still
need a
two-state solution it is the only answer
and i'm prepared to put together and are
going to attempt to put together
a major package with
other nations who share our view to
rebuild the homes
and without re-engaging without
providing hamas the opportunity to
rebuild their weapon systems
rebuild the the gaza
rebuild gaza and they need the help
and i'm committed to get that done
after 11 days of conflict the ceasefire
is holding
and the borders of gaza have reopened
our correspondent mark stone was amongst
those returning and spoke to people
mourning
their dead it's only an hour and a bits
drive from jerusalem down to gaza
through an israeli checkpoint which they
have now opened after 11 days
and with multiple vehicle changes it is
a journey
into a different world the damage of the
past two weeks of bombings is quickly
clear
and so too is the relief of the people
here they can finally emerge into
streets
which are safe no one here knows why
this building was hit
a residential block in the neighborhood
of bet hanoon
but inside celebrating eid last week
were two families
among them bilal miriam yamin
yusuf and in the middle maria
ten people are now dead they were all
women and children
nearby awake the ceasefire has allowed
for people to gather
to mourn
maria survived that night with her
father ala abu hatib
they are the only two from the family
still alive
foreign the israeli military insists
that this
wasn't them they say a hamas rocket fell
short
and that in time they will prove it but
then
no hamas rockets which have hit israel
have caused anything like this damage
we move on through the narrow streets
and passed more wakes for a meeting with
a hamas official
dr basim naim is a surgeon by training
but speaks for hamas
and defends its actions any people
under occupation based on the
international law have the
all the right to defend themselves by
all feasible means they have
not by firing rockets from a civilian
population i have said it clearly
palestinians as an occupied people have
the right to defend themselves
by all feasible means including our
resistance but when it comes
to civilians we have said that many
times we are ready to stop
firing rockets or attacking civilians
if this really stop attacking our people
would you sit down with an israeli
to talk this through why to sit with him
my my demands are clear i don't
i don't need to sit with him we have
achieved a lot without sitting with each
other
back in bait hanoon more friends of the
abu hatibs offer their support
one family just two people now but a
pain
shared mark stone sky news in gaza
let's take a look now at some of the
morning's other news for you
[Music]
and this is the uk's entry for tonight's
eurovision song contest
in rotterdam the song is called embers
and is performed by james newman
he's hoping to improve on the
competition from that 2019 when the uk
came last i think it's
it's kind of scary but also exciting
because
i've like building up to it doing loads
of practice loads of rehearsals lots of
singing lessons
i feel like i'm like training for like a
boxing match or something so
um hopefully fingers crossed when i get
on the stage i've done everything i can
to be the best that i can
the glastonbury festival will return
with the live stream event tonight
featuring some of the biggest names in
music
acts including haim coldplay and damon
albarn will perform
at worthy farm in somerset
experts from the royal botanic gardens
have begun work on a project to find
natural solutions to current
environmental problems they want to
create a so-called
living laboratory which not only looks
good but also helps to absorb
carbon shingi mararike reports
the british countryside something many
have become more familiar with than ever
over the past year places like q
wakehurst which is home to 500 acres of
woodland
flora and fauna have provided us with
much needed relief
but today it becomes even more than that
these meadows are now the backdrop for a
new living laboratory
exploring the benefits of a biodiverse
british landscape
scientists here are hopeful that the
idea will grow into more than just a
research project
they wanted to change the way policy
makers landowners
and conservation bodies approach the
environment
we have been very lucky that we've spent
a lot of time over many many years
enriching this landscape really asking
of every habitat what's the best
range of species that we can create
what's the best way that we can care for
this
estate we know it's a good landscape but
we now want to prove it so we want to
use
cue science's amazing research skills to
start to build
evidence for why a biodiverse landscape
like this matters
from today cue scientists will study
this patchwork of fields and flowers
focusing on four pillars of research
carbon
pollination hydrology and human
well-being
starting from the ground up they want to
branch out and address the big question
everybody wants to know whether the
landscape has a role in absorbing carbon
can it help us to get to this net zero
target by 2050
we know that planting trees is important
for absorbing carbon
but we also think that really well
managed stable long-term landscapes are
good for locking carbon up
it's not just about woodlands and plants
here at the living laboratory in
kuwaitcus
researchers are also interested in the
importance of insects
in ensuring that we live in a biodiverse
landscape
if we don't have enough insects not just
the ones that control pests in our crops
or not just the ones that pollinate our
crops
if we don't have enough insects we won't
have the birds we won't have
all of those parts of the food chain
that enable us to maintain
a rich biodiversity the work here won't
just preserve invertebrates and the
slightly larger members of the food
chain
one of the biggest benefits of taking
care of our landscape
is the role doing this plays in taking
care of ourselves
shingi marurike sky news wakehouse
and a reminder that you can watch the
sky news daily climate show that's at 6
30 p.m and
9 30 p.m every weekday
time now to take a look at the actual
weather for you with kirsty
um and i can see out the window
[Laughter]
it's not great it's better than
yesterday is it
yeah it is it is or it will be in a
little bit so yes the forecast is
somewhat better as we go through the
recipe and today for many of us will be
the best day
there is more wet and windy weather to
come on sunday but a heads up for
further ahead of that it is going to
settle down hang on in there
i'll bring you the details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning yesterday's weather was
pretty grim
rather wet and very windy now that windy
weather is eventually clearing away
still a risk of gales for
eastern coast as we go through the
morning but it is improving
and the cloudy skies to start the day
across much of england and wales but
that cloud will thin
and break as well the rain lingering for
time across the far east and far south
but also
becoming drier we have already got some
brighter skies across scotland
northern ireland and ireland a few
showers mixed in with that but the
brighter shady weather will start to
extend its way further east
through the rest of the day and where
you get the sunshine it might actually
feel
a little bit more like spring
temperatures peaking 11 to maybe 14
degrees so it's still just below the
average
the cloudy skies may cling on for a time
across east anglia really into the
afternoon but elsewhere is
sunny spells and scattered showers and
with lighter winds
it will feel warmer than yesterday
through the night tonight it'll be a bit
chilly with clear skies but we've got
wet and windy weather moving in from the
west
through tomorrow so tomorrow another
wetter and windier one
more now on our top story and the
fallout from the dyson report into the
bbc interview with princess diana
less than two years after she spoke to
martin beshear
princess diana lost her life and prince
william has now said he believes
the interview contributed to his
mother's paranoia and isolation
a friend of diana's has told sky news
while the interview was
contrived the princess wanted to do it
iver bennett reports for diana the life
of a princess
meant a life in front of the lens
cameras followed her
wherever she went
[Music]
by day it was on the roadside
by night on the red carpet publicity
that
ultimately became too much i was not
aware of how overwhelming
that attention would become simone
simmons was a friend of diana's and was
with her when she arranged to speak to
martin bashir
but she says the interview that was
recorded was not the one that was agreed
she was so excited he's going to do a
documentary about my
charities and all the good work she
had wanted to do some
form of an interview to get back at
charles
but not one that was so
contrived to make her totally paranoid
to escape her marriage and the media
glare diana spent much of her time at
kensington palace
but it served as both her refuge and her
prison
diana's paranoia was evident well before
she agreed to do the panorama
interview and it got to the point where
when a new fire alarm was being
installed here
according to her private secretary at
the time diana was convinced
it was actually the building being
bugged the interview with the bbc
wasn't the first time diana told her
story many of its revelations had
already appeared in print
in a book that was written it was later
revealed with her help
but it still contained moments that
shocked even those who knew her
when she said in terms my husband prince
charles
isn't fit to be king and she questioned
his wish to be
king at that moment you know in an
earlier age that's what they call les
majeste
i i i almost almost heard the axes being
sharpened in the background after a
fairy tale beginning
her life in the spotlight slowly
unravelled a public persona
adored the world over but in private
this was someone
who felt increasingly isolated and alone
those vulnerabilities
now laid bare once again iva bennett
sky news
the u.s president joe biden says a
two-state solution is the only answer to
resolving the conflict between israel
and the palestinian people earlier we
heard from residents of gaza who say
they fear conflict will return one day
those same worries are present in
israeli communities
on the border our foreign affairs editor
debra haynes reports from ashdod
families here didn't have time to race
to a communal shelter before the rocket
struck last monday
i keep having flashes that what if the
bomb hit that side
if it hit that side we wouldn't be alive
for sure
do you feel like a little bit calmer
today because there's no sirens yeah
sure
sure i feel calmer today but i'm
concerned about the future because today
is okay but i have no idea what's going
to happen next year
no one in this jewish neighborhood in
southern israel was killed
but everyone's shaken katya told me
how she protected her two young
daughters
yeah and i was just lying on top of them
a neighbor helped rescue them
they didn't speak only in the hospital
when
the paramedics were treating us that's
where they started to speak a little bit
one floor down more evidence of trauma
the gorensteins were at home when the
blast happened and you can see it
absolutely devastated their apartment
windows smashed in cupboards hanging off
the wall rubble
on the floor and they say well they're
relieved that the ceasefire has been
cooled like many people here they just
wonder how long it's going to last
the damage here while bad is
incomparable with the scenes in gaza
but this is still a community reeling
the threat of palestinian rocket fire
forced this vet
at a nearby kibbutz to close for the
first time
in years of on off conflict today's her
first day back
she thinks israel's airstrikes were
worthwhile to deter hamas
though she's also no fan of her own
prime minister
i think it's time for him to go it's
been too long already
and i think that we have to have a
change here
we need to be uh we need to do the
change it's enough
lilly says the whole country now needs
to mend arabs
and jews it damaged us but it's like a
wound
and we will heal and maybe it will make
us stronger
people want to say that we live together
people that
do living in cooperation and
want to shout it out and to say there is
a different way we can do it differently
together
and i hope the silent voices will rise
more and more
if not the wounds on both sides will
only worsen
debra haynes sky news ashdod
earlier this week we brought you a
report from inside an eating disorder
unit
showing the reality of an illness which
is affecting more and more young people
during the pandemic
for those who are coming through
treatment moving on can be filled
with hope but also apprehension sky's
nick martin spoke to one teenager who
spent
months in hospital this is melissa's
story and just to warn you there are
references to eating disorders
and feeding through the nose in this
report
this is the room where i spent quite a
few months
melissa has mixed feelings about being
here
it's both a place of hurt and healing
and not always in equal measure i
definitely remember lying
on that bed every single night and just
wishing i was at home
in my own bed with my own family
and not having to dread waking up the
next morning
she's a patient on this ward for
children and adolescents and she's being
treated for the eating disorder
anorexia nervosa everyone around you
just wants you to be safe and wants to
help but
you really that is the last thing in
that moment that you want
what what are the pressures that make
things more difficult for you do you
think
um although i do love
being in college i think that's
definitely a big big pressure
um the same with like
friends and peer groups i think although
that is a good thing i think it is still
another big pressure
isn't the thing to sort of perform to i
suppose
and so the paradox of that is the things
that you actually like
are on the other side of the coin the
things that you actually hate at the
same time yeah
definitely eating disorder referrals
have doubled during the pandemic
and alongside the care and compassion
here there is a stark reality
that nurses often have to feed patients
via a tube
just to keep them alive i think it's
genuinely up there with one of the worst
things i've ever had to go through
and physically it's such an awful
feeling
and then obviously as well it's
it's really horrible just having that
sort of happening to
you and you know at the same time that
you can't
control it or stop it um
and i think it gets to a point where you
i think i can definitely remember
sitting there having that
having that done to me and thinking like
how did it actually get to this
um it's a very very cruel illness
to see your daughter your young daughter
as a child as she was she still is a
child but as a young child
sobbing her heart out because she knows
she's got to eat that meal
and you're sitting there
sort of forcing her into it
and it's horrible sorry it's really
horrible
you know she's got to do it
you've got to make her do it you're
making her do something
that is really really awful for her
and you're doing it for all the right
reasons and i think deep down she knows
that
but it's utterly heartbreaking to say
it really is
do you think that they saved your life
in this room
i think yeah looking back on it now i
think definitely
um yeah i think there definitely are
negatives and drawbacks to it but
i think it it does save lives it
it is really important and i've met some
amazing people along the way
um and i don't want that to go unmissed
along
alongside it do you want to get better
i think in principle i do
but i think it's putting that into
action that i struggle with
so for me it feels like a happy ending
for you
because i've journeyed through since
your time here
there is hope here melissa is being
discharged
which means she can go home but the
family have been here before
so there's always that sort of worry at
the back of my mind
as to how are we going to to manage this
will it
you know will this be the time she does
manage to stay out
and i was looking through some work that
you completed for me and
and i kind of talked a bit about how
home is so
lovely and safe for you that makes
me feel happy that discharge has come
and
you're going
[Applause]
okay thank you thanks a lot bye
bye bye
for melissa this is a new start and
everyone here hopes
she can continue to get better but the
pandemic has revealed that many more
youngsters
will need this kind of treatment and
sadly their journey
is just beginning nick martin sky news
and if you've been affected by any of
the issues in that report you can
contact the samaritans on 116
123 or email joe samaritans.org
it is time now to take a look at the
weather for you with kirsty
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning after yes it is very wet
and unseasonably windy weather
we are looking at slightly better
conditions for the weekend although
not completely dry unfortunately but the
wind
has eased a lot still a small risk of
coastal gills in the far east but for
many
it is a less windy start to the day a
little bit grain damp across parts of
england
and wales but the rain will start to
ease in the east and the south
scotland northern ireland and ireland
sunshine and showers here
and that showery mix will start to
extend its way across england and wales
as we go through the rest of the day
temperature is still a little bit below
the average but feeling more like spring
for you get the sunshine
although saying that it will take some
time for the brighter skies to get all
the way over
towards parts of east anglia where we
have the clear skies tonight it will be
a rather chilly one
a few showers around the coast and then
this band of rain coming in across
ireland
into northern ireland by the end of the
night so wetter and windier weather
moving its way eastwards during the day
on sunday but some bright weather
further north and east for much of the
day with us this morning to take us
through the newspapers now the
broadcaster and journalist bedisha
and a senior fellow from the policy
exchange calvin
robinson welcome to you both good
morning uh starting with you first of
all bedisha you've had a look at the
times front page um and uh prince harry
pictured there and this story really
about uh the pain that he's
felt ever since the death of his his
mother very very sad isn't that
it's very sad it's incredibly revelatory
so this is
all based on prince harry and the great
broadcaster oprah's new series all about
mental health it's called
the me you can't see it's a long very
lavish in
conversations series and prince harry
opens up in a way that he had
done prior prior to this in his original
oprah interview but he gives even more
details he talks about how
following the death of his mother diana
in 1997 he's self-medicated with
drink and drugs and how he drank as much
on a saturday night or a friday night as
he had
during the week and about how his grief
was exacerbated by
the paparazzi and he felt that the same
system the same people the same tactics
were being used against his wife meghan
markle as they had been against his
mother
diana read all the details online
there's been lots of leaking and
splurging about this the reason i
brought this up is because it ties
together
a few different things talking about
mental health talking about grief and
family dynamics
talking about the unique strange
position of being a prince where he
complains about having his game face on
and having to
say yes and be the yes man of the family
and talking about
old structures so not just the press and
the paparazzi but also
the entire royal family gotta be frank
i'm not a hundred percent sure that
that saying all of this stuff is going
to somehow resolve his
relationships with his family but uh
lots of details there are lots of
interesting very big issues
at the moment that we're all talking
about and maybe it takes someone of the
stature of prince harry
and meghan markle and oprah winfrey to
bring these debates into the mainstream
calvin it's only going to make things
worse in terms of the relationship with
his family isn't it
it's outrageous isn't it so much for
wanting extra privacy
um you know we've heard stories already
that prince harry is saying archie's
first words my grandma diana it's all
very crass it seems to be like he's
cashing in on on
his poor late mother's name i'm very sad
to see all of this or is he just being
open about
his his experience um with with his
mental health
and what he's been through after what we
saw with the last oprah interview
that's not i don't think that's the case
it looks to me like they're launching a
u.s career it's very crisis
it's not pleasant to see uh you know go
to therapy privately
sure but don't do it on national
television or international television
for the world to see and shaming his
family in this way
the stories he's bringing up about his
family very personal very intimate
uh very private well possibly part of
his healing you could see it that way
let's
look at the guardian staying with the
royals and they're talking about um
well the fiori now over that interview
that
diana gave to martin bashir and the
responsibilities of of the bbc although
from the tone of this article it's
saying that the interview is going to be
used as a weapon to be used against the
bbc now
absolutely and rightly so this is the
lead story of course in the guardian
this is a big story right here
the former chair of the bbc trust is
warning about this feeding frenzy and of
course there should be a feeding frenzy
on the bbc here we had her royal
highness the princess of wales
was tricked into an interview with lies
fake documents
fraud outright manipulated by the bbc
and it was covered up
for years after complaints at the time
and complaints up until today it was all
swept under the carpet
it's out of order it's outrageous any
other time period if this was happening
to the royal family
that would have been classed as treason
so it's out it's completely
appropriate for ofcom to be
investigating this and it's
completely appropriate for ministers
government ministers to be looking at
how the bbc's governed uh i would say i
i really thought his royal highness the
prince of
uh prince william gave a real classy
uh speech with full of integrity he
showed himself to be a future king in
his statement that was fantastic to see
what would you say to
to those who who've openly said and
we've spoken to it to one of uh princess
diana's friends that
she would have done an interview anyway
and she wanted to do the interview even
if it hadn't been with the bbc
i'm sure she would but she would have
answered the questions probably in a
very different way
you know when you're shown information
that you think the bbc already has when
the interviewer has these so-called
scoops on you you're going to answer the
questions in a very different way than
you would otherwise you'd probably
protect yourself and protect your family
a little bit more
if you'd if you thought that they didn't
know certain things so i think she was
manipulated you know and it was fraud it
was outright forward
she was showing bank statements that
were made up by people like the bbc it's
outrageous what happened and we need to
really investigate it make sure that
this never happens again
and the bbc should pay a costly price
for it yeah it is under the microscope
to say the least at the moment but he
should do the i uh and we're all sort of
thinking about that the summer months
will we be able to go abroad or not some
people deciding
not to but for those who have children
and potentially take
them abroad the issues with quarantining
when they get back and what what excuses
given to the school and whether
all of that should be allowed uh yeah
i'm not sure it quite rises to the
height of treason this particular story
and i'm also not sure it quite
feels very summery yet so we might be
thinking about it but we're not sure
so the issue is that a country like
spain
is one of the most visited hot spots for
uk travelers
we visit there in our millions every
single year now spain is on the
ambulance that means that when you go
you need to come back and quarantine for
10 days afterwards
this makes a problem because if you do
that it means that your kids will not be
in school for the start of
the next bit of the term the government
doesn't want
parents to have their kids out of school
without the head teacher's permission
there are fines put in place on a sort
of parking
fine system so 60 quid if you if you pay
up immediately 120
if you desist at the same time however
they don't want parents to
lie about traveling and put their kids
back in school after holiday
without quarantining because that's not
safe
so what we do know is that a few leaky
little moles in the government have been
saying that they don't really want to
under
undermine the quarantine system by
forcing parents to pay
fines we're going to go ahead as
if it's okay just about to visit the
ambulance countries spain is accepting
tourists and then to try to try trying
quarantine but
somehow not uh make the parents
all the teachers the head teachers look
like the bad guys in
in this so they're trying to square the
circle around
holiday and quarantining but i have to
be frank i don't think that you're going
to have to pay a fine
if you do indeed go on holidays you know
my position on on the pandemic i'm very
orthodox i like to follow the rules
having said that that desire amongst
families to go on holidays
is completely and utterly understandable
by this stage because we're a year and
two months into into it so i do
understand all of these drives but
but also the medics concerns we can't
have this pandemic
start growing again no no but but do you
think that
even if there were fines to be imposed
that that some
parents would just consider it part of
the holiday cost
i think that if you're privileged in the
sense that you can afford all of that in
terms of time and money there certainly
will be families who think about that
one of the proposals that's been put
forward by government advisors is to say
okay you know how we did it in in the
education system at the beginning of the
pandemic we used
remote learning we had lots of tools and
resources online maybe that's a way of
bridging the gap so that you don't have
kids
basically quarantining at home with
absolutely nothing to do
when term time and all of their friends
are at school that's the solution that's
being suggested
calvin very quickly we're running out of
time sorry about that the uh telegraph
um in about 50 seconds tell me about
this story to do with them
a new law to fight phone scammers
absolutely so the police are encouraging
the government and phone companies to
take more responsibility over this
pandemic we've seen so many more of
these phone scammers what they can do is
they can clone
numbers and send text messages that
appear to be from your bank
or appear to be from the royal mail and
say you know you've got a failed
delivery could you please
click this link to pay two pounds to
receive your pass or things like that
they're preying on the vulnerable and we
need to stamp it out in order to do that
the government the police and the phone
companies need to work together to
ensure that these
these horrible scammers stop praying on
vulnerable people and stop
faking phone calls and text messages in
order to scan people of their
hard-earned cash
yeah it is annoying we've all got those
texts haven't we calvin and bedisha
thank you so much